trains ground to a halt in the capital
giving ukrainians a safe place to
shelter as the rocket attack warning
siren Wales from above ground the
muffled thud of explosions
our anti-missile system works quite well
but due to the high quantity of cruise
missiles
shot by Russian federations launched by
Russian Federation we still face some
difficulties difficulties like the loss
of power heat and water Ukrainian
officials say Russia again targeted
energy infrastructure sites this time
roughly nine power stations were knocked
offline affecting about 50 percent of
the energy Grid
in herkiv there was a total blackout but
locals got to work at what's called an
invincibility Center
we heard explosions the power went out
people need to be fed we are here
cooking on a wood stove
[Applause]
generators air defense and the will of
the people three things Ukraine's Deputy
interior Minister says we'll see them
through these dark and bitterly cold
days they're taking our energy
infrastructure making people suffer
during the winter time that's about
genocide of our nation but I must admit
that our moral is extremely strong and
we will never surrender
with that fight comes death and
destruction in kivari several lives were
lost and more than a dozen people were
injured as night fell Crews were still
digging through the rubble of what's
left of a residential apartment building
one child was unaccounted for his
parents and a 64 year old woman had been
killed
Crystal commencing Global News London